- Good morning, I hope
you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm in Trat, Thailand
and this is day four of
our eastern provinces
of Thailand food and travel tour.
Today I have a very special day for you.
We are on our way to Baan Huai Raeng,
which is a community
in the forests in Trat,
and they are gonna cook for us some local,
very seasonal dishes, using some
of the local ingredients from this area.
I'm not sure what
they're gonna cook for us
but I know it's gonna be
delicious and I'm gonna share
it all with you in this video right now.
(engaging music)
It was about a 25 minute
drive to get here from
the center of Trat Town and we are at
Wat Plai Klong, which is
a temple where someone
from the community is about to pick us up
and then we're gonna get started cooking
and eating, they should
be here any minute.
(upbeat tropical music)
They came to pick us up.
We are following them
into the village now.
(upbeat tropical music)
Okay and here we are.
Oh wow, this place,
this place is gorgeous.
(conversing in foreign language)
- Lots of friendly dogs, we
have met up with the family;
this is where we're gonna cook, this is
where we're gonna eat, it's gorgeous.
They're fruit trees; it's lush.
Oh wow, this house is absolutely gorgeous.
You gotta love that doormat:
an old pair of jeans
but you walk up to this
platform, it's elevated,
it's a huge communal platform,
this is traditional Trat
style and it's gorgeous.
I mean you have the open air breeze;
you have this whole
community section here.
I think the kitchen is back
there and then over on this side
you have more of the room
section where you can sleep,
and they have the mosquito
nets over there as well.
I'm loving it already.
(speaking in foreign language)
(pan scrapes)
(upbeat tropical music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- It's actually gonna be a
very, it's not just fried rice,
it's gonna be combined
with a bunch of ingredients
and wrapped up in some
time of leaf wrapper
but also a banana leaf, so we're
gonna go get a banana leaf too.
(adventurous music)
Oh, this is a tropical paradise,
there are durian trees,
bananas, mangosteen,
rambutan, and it's not
quite there in season yet, so
you can see the little dirt;
oh I just got bit by an ant.
Oh yeah look at that ant.
(foot smashes)
(speaks foreign language)
- You remember the dish
it's called chamuang
which in English it's
called cowa garcinia.
Oh I'm so getting bit by ants.
Cowa garcinia leaves, this
is the tree right here,
these are the leaves; I know
it's an evergreen type of tree
but it's very, very commonly eaten
in this region of eastern Thailand.
They literally have
everything that you need
for a Trat Thai feast within their yard,
within this jungle, it's
gorgeous, absolutely gorgeous.
(upbeat tropical music)
What's the actual name of it?
(speaks foreign language)
- It's like a little purse,
(speaks foreign language),
and that's the official
name of it; so she took some
of the fried rice stirred
fried with that numb pig
and the she adds in all the
components of ingredients,
specifically quite a lot
of pineapple, a cucumber,
a salted egg, and a handful
of cashews, and fried fish.
And that all gets wrapped
up first into a banana leaf
and then into that extra giant leaf,
and she makes a pear-shape,
that's, that's cool.
(utensils clank)
- [Presenter] Michael
can you show your haul?
So that's like a little lunch box purse
that's all everything you need for
a complete meal wrapped up in that leaf.
Something else that's very
cool, and I didn't know this
from the start is that
this is a little spoon,
all-natural, and that she
includes in this packet.
And even this string, this is all natural,
this is made from the same
wrapper, the greater wrapper.
It's absolutely beautiful.
A little packet, the spoon
is particularly cool,
this is what I'm most excited to use.
I'm gonna get a little
bit of that salted egg.
bit of that pineapple,
that fish, and oh I have a cashew,
I gotta have a cashew on this bite too.
Scoop up a little bit
and there's also a purple
sweet potato in the rice
as well, oh what a bite!
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh that's delicious.
I mean the rice has a little
bit of a shrimp paste flavor
to it, I think there's some
shrimp paste in that nam phrik,
and then you've got the
starchy pieces of sweet potato;
you've got that sweet
balance of acidic pineapple,
and then the crunchy fish, that's awesome.
That's such like a soothing mix.
(speaking in foreign language)
- It's really, awesomely good.
Yeah, it's just such a
harmony of ingredients
and so many different things going on.
(speaks foreign language)
- She's getting me immediately
started on the next dish
and she's making a curry with
this fruit called kradom,
and if I were just to guess,
I've never seen it before
in Thailand, I've never
seen it before in my life,
but if I were to guess
it looks pretty sour,
with little green fruits
like that, but the first step
is that I could be totally
wrong, the first step is
she added some salt and she's just mixing
that around and then they're
gonna cook it with shrimp.
(pan rushes)
Back in the kitchen they are
squeezing the coconut milk
by hand that you know it's gonna
be that that ups the notch,
fresh coconut milk that
makes all the difference.
(speaking in foreign language)
(upbeat tropical music)
- While the curry was cooking
we headed out to forage
a seasonal ingredient along
the banks of the water.
We are now going off into a
boat to get an ingredient;
it's a leaf, I'm not
totally sure what it is,
I've never had it before,
we're gonna get the leaf;
we're gonna bring it back
and they're gonna make
one more dish and then we're gonna eat.
I can't wait to try that
other curry with the shrimp
and then the other dish
that she's gonna make.
(leaves rustle)
So the house is actually
right next to a river.
(conversing in foreign language)
(engine revs)
(upbeat tropical music)
- And again he told me
this was brackish water
and that's part of the
reason why the fruit
and the ingredients in
this area are so good;
they say because of the brackish water
the mangoes are extremely sweet.
(engaging music)
(speaks foreign language)
- And this is the type of
leaf, I think it's a vine
actually, it's the red vine,
it has a red color to it.
It looks like it's kinda tangled with
some bamboo and that's
what we're gonna get.
(leafs crunch)
Wow, the whole vine.
(speaks foreign language)
- He's pulled that vine off, that
is straight forage to leaves, vines, from
the jungle for the dish he's gonna make.
(upbeat tropical music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- We're back at the house now,
with that leaf, with that vine,
they're gonna make gaeng
som which is a sour curry.
Gaeng som by Son Don.
- [Presenter Voiceover] While
the menu is being prepared
we took another break
to eat another pre-meal.
This time a royal Thai dish
called Kanom Jeen Sao Nam
Uncle had made it himself
for the family and we
just happened to have honor
to be there for the occasion.
- This was a surprise I
didn't even know they were
making this dish but it's
called Kanom Jeen Sao Nam,
and this is a really old,
traditional Thai dish,
very hard to find, but it's a summer dish
in the hot weather you eat
with the khao kan chin,
which is the soft rice
noodles and you have all
the different components, with the curry,
yeah, it's fantastic, and we're all
sitting down to eat it right now.
(plates scrape)
(speaks foreign language)
- There are so many ingredients.
This is an exciting dish to eat.
(uptempo music)
- [Presenter] Pineapple?
- [Male] Yeah.
- [Presenter] This is ginger?
- [Male] Yes.
- [Presenter] Raw garlic.
(people converse in foreign language)
- [Presenter] I got all the components
and now it's time to add
the real, actual curry
with the fish meatballs in here.
I'm gonna add it to the side there.
(woman speaks foreign language)
- [Presenter] The fish balls are fresh
and they are very spongy; oh the garlic
and the ginger down there too.
I need a little bit of all of this.
(conversing in foreign language)
- Oh wow.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And uncle is telling us
that he made this special,
very special, it was completely unplanned.
The sum of all the ingredients together
that makes it spectacular;
you've got the coconut milk
with the fish balls,
you've got what I like
is the ginger and garlic
but paired with that salty
fish sauce and then the sweet pineapple.
What a contrast.
What a delicious mix in your
mouth and this is actually
a traditional Royal Palace Thai dish.
(speaks foreign language)
- [Presenter] So I can get a half?
- Yeah.
- Okay it's so good, I need
some more, a little bit more.
(speaking in foreign language)
- There's no way you'll
not have a re-fill of this.
The entire sum of the
ingredients, but these fish balls
are notable, they are
stunning, that springy texture,
all-natural, all-fish,
he just pounds it with
salt he said, and he pounded
it by hand, the fish balls;
that's why they're all
random shapes and sizes,
and those are some of the
fish balls you'll ever have.
It's awesome and I really
don't know what we're doing;
the day has sort of
shifted, we're just kind
of hanging around eating and
I'm loving every moment of it.
(upbeat tropical music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(pot whirs)
- At first I can see he
added the chili paste,
he added some extra chilies, and then
he just added in some sour tamarind.
(speaking in foreign language)
(pot clinks and stews)
- It's barracuda, very fresh
barracuda, and he said:
once you add in the fish and
the shrimp you don't wanna
stir it very much or it
will get a bad smell.
(upbeat tropical music)
(speaks in foreign language)
- He put in the entire
heap of those leaves
and that was a mound of leaves,
and they immediately turn
from a bright green color to
a kind of brown-green color.
(speaks in foreign language)
- And final step is to
add in a bunch of shrimp.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Mm, mm, okay should have three flavors,
sour, salty, sweet.
- Yes.
Switzerland, bye.
(speaks foreign language)
- Sourness coming from the
leaves and the tamarind.
Oh, that's beautifully sour.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We are sitting down yet
again to eat but these are
the two dishes that are
specifically the seasonal
dishes from this region in
Trat; these are ingredients
the forage divines and then that other
little fruit with the shrimp curry,
it looks delicious and I
can't wait to taste it.
So this one is the gaeng
kradom with the little fruits,
they're all below here,
all of that coconut milk,
and then the shrimp; I
have to just taste some
of that fruit first
with some of that curry.
- Wow, I like. I like.
(speaks foreign language)
- Okay that's exactly right,
he's telling me you get
the bitter first taste and
then as you keep on chewing
it's starts to get a little
sweeter as it goes down.
But yeah, I was totally
expecting it to be sour,
not really sour; but yeah
it is bitter, kind of like
bitter corn, but a more subtle bitter;
then it's wrapped up in
that fresh coconut milk
and then it's a little
bit spicy, you've got
that shrimp inside of there,
oh, that's spectacular.
That's fantastic. I love that bitterness.
Okay and next up is the
gaeng som by Son Don,
which again is that leaf
and there's fish in here,
and we saw him make the
whole thing in these
giant prawn shrimp, ah but that leaf;
I'm most excited about that leaf.
Those leaves are outstanding,
such a sour flavor,
when you cook them, they
really are more soft
and more silky than
spinach; they require almost
no chewing, they just sort
of dissolve in your mouth.
And he was very careful
not to overcook the shrimp;
oh wow, these are very
soft though, the shell.
First eat the shrimp then I'll chase it
with this bite of rice
with some of the leaves.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh, that shrimp is incredible.
It's so tender and then the
mangoun which is the tamale,
the head and butter juices,
it's so creamy and so rich.
What a fantastic leaf
and doesn't get better
than foraged leaves and vegetables.
Just wild, natural supreme, that's one
of those leaves that's
so sour it immediately
leaves that sour sour
chalkiness on your teeth.
(upbeat tropical music)
And that one is spectacular too.
You know they're both really good.
Both totally, completely
opposite in flavors.
(tropical upbeat music)
And on our way out the
family graciously gave us
an entire bagful of bananas
right from their garden.
What a fantastic day. What delicious food.
And a little insight
into the village life,
community life in Trat; a
big thank you to the family
for hosting us and grandma for cooking,
and uncle also those special dishes.
We didn't really plan much
of what we we were gonna do
and it just unfolded as it did.
I'll have some information
in the description box below
but the the community is
called Baan Huai Raeng,
and please remember to give
this video a thumbs up,
and if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now
and also click the little bell icon so
that you get notified of
all the future videos.
Thanks again for watching and I
will see you on the next video.